first we turn to some disturbing news
surrounding joe biden
after well inexplicably canceling
multiple public events over the past two
weeks
joe is now struggling to well even form
sentences and speak at times in what is
a coherent way
earlier he attempted to use a cheat
sheet
to deliver some extemporaneous remarks
uh it didn't exactly go well take a look
i promise you we are going to together
beat this
and uh and i think that uh i
uh you know but the idea that um
over 500 i have a card i carry a
card with me every day
with the total number of folks who have
been affected by
the uh
as of uh yesterday
there were 500 one people have died from
this
oh and the media likes to attack me for
saying yeah he looks weak frail and it
seems to be struggling
cognitively what's on the note card joe
your name
your address contact information name of
your wife
what your address is 1600 pennsylvania
avenue if you get lost
a reminder not to mention the corrupt
family business
in all honesty this is now getting scary
he is supposed to be our
commander-in-chief
and this is probably the toughest and
single most demanding job in the world
that's why you can't have a media mob
big
tech candidate protection program and
run a campaign hiding in your basement
bunker
and joe seemingly can barely form a
sentence in between naps
and meanwhile there is a serious
developing situation
right at our southern border after biden
vowed to allow more refugees into the
u.s
and halted all border wall construction
illegal crossings are now way up not a
surprise
now this includes kids under the age of
18.
that is forcing the biden administration
to open an emergency facility for kids
or as the media mob used to call it
under donald trump kids in cages
this time they're actually tiny trailers
that look like
shipping containers with bars on the
windows
but washington post of course media
outlet of all things radical socialist
they are politely referring to this as a
migrant facility for children
oh with bars on the windows we're going
to talk about the hypocrisy coming up
but first let's take a step back and
let's review how we got here
we start the years 2014 and that's when
then president
obama encountered a massive wave of
migrant caravans filled with
unaccompanied minors
in order to process and house these
migrants the obama administration
acquired a warehouse
and they used you got it a chain link
fence to divide
children from adults in the following
years the trump administration
they continued to use the obama facility
for unaccompanied minors and other
migrant children
whose parents were being prosecuted for
crimes they did the same thing obama did
this was a temporary holding facility
where children were housed for less than
a week
but in 2018 the mob the media they
became hysterical after
they unearthed photos circulating
showing kids behind a chain-link fence
well as it turns out many of those
photos were actually from the obama era
but the truth that doesn't seem to
matter to the media mob
to democrats to big tech companies they
only seem to care about smearing
slandering besmirching attacking donald
trump
every second minute hour of every day so
they accused him of
putting kids in cages washington post
wrote that the chain-link fence
was a symbol of mistreatment kamala
harris herself called it
immoral and wrong and unnecessary joe
biden said that it was one of the
darkest moments in our history
well he did it congresswoman alexandria
ocasio-cortez
visited one of the facilities at the
border and dramatically
wept in front of a photographer while
clinging to a chain-link fence
and in a matter of weeks president trump
ended the child separation policy
ultimately closed the south texas
facility for renovations
now thanks to the obama administration a
brand new
beautiful holding facility for kids with
bars on the windows is back
that's open for business now these tiny
things that look like
shipping containers are now housing
underage migrants we just can't see them
the washington post is praising the
facilities
and highlighting all the wonderful
amenities including quote
colorful trailer at the entryway
where flowers and butterflies and
handmade posters hang on its walls
tonight to her credit congresswoman
ocasio-cortez
at least she is a democrat that is being
consistent
and she's blasting the biden
administration but press secretary
jensaki wants you to know that these are
definitely not cages like the last time
they're delightful trailers that look
like shipping containers
with bars on the windows and butterflies
and sunshine and cotton candy
on the walls take a look it's the same
facility that was open
for a month in the trump administration
summer 2019
that is when joe biden said under trump
there have been horrifying scenes at the
border of kids being kept in cages and
kamala harris said
uh basically babies and cages is a human
rights
abuse being committed by the united
states government so how is this any
different than that
we very much feel that way it's not
under trump it's under biden
this is not kids being kept in cages
this is
this is kids this is a facility that was
opened
that's going to follow the same
standards as other hhs facilities it is
not a replication
certainly not though that's that is
never our intention of replicating the
immigration policies of the past
administration
let me make a prediction chansaki she's
going to
circle back on this one since the
situation at the southern border
is only going to get dramatically worse
that you could take to the bank biden's
open border policies
are a green light for migrants and in
the coming weeks and months
mark my words there will be another huge
massive uptick in illegal immigration
now this is especially true given that
biden's pick for attorney general
merrick garland
isn't even sure that illegal immigration
is illegal he wants to be attorney
general
illegal immigration he's not sure is
illegal okay
take a look do you believe that illegal
entry at america's border should remain
a crime
well i haven't thought about that
question uh
i just haven't thought about that
question i i think you know
the president has uh made clear that we
are a country of
uh with the borders and with the concern
about national security
um i don't know of a proposal to uh
decriminalize but still make it uh
unlawful to
enter i just don't know the answer to
that question i haven't thought about it
let me guess he'll circle back also by
the way when i went to one of my many
trips to the border maybe
13 14 of them one time i took one of my
feet and i stepped over the other side
and then i was accused of the legal
entry back into the country
one step over can you believe obama the
mob the media tried to
sell that guy as the next great moderate
u.s supreme court justice
he's going to circle back make no
mistake there is a looming crisis at our
southern border
the biden administration is only going
to make it worse